-Here's the deal, okay?
-Okay.
-We're going to hear a question.
-Yes.
-Whoever buzzes in first
[ Buzzer ]
gets to -- No, not yet!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Gets to answer it.
-If you -- If you get
the number 1 answer,
you automatically win the round.
But if you don't,
the other person has a chance
to answer
and steal the round.
[ Buzzer ]
No, not yet.
-Look it.
He is upset about that.
Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not, no.
This is all fun and games.
-Okay. Sure.
[ Buzzer ]
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Now, look, we surveyed
our great audience
and the top 3 answers are
on the board.
-Okay.
-Let's hear the first question.
[ Buzzer ]
-The drugs!
[ Laughter and applause ]
I said that?
[ Ding ]
I didn't say that.
That's Cookie!
-Oh, you got it right there.
Oh, my gosh, that's it.
You got it.
Alcohol/drugs. That's a win
right there, right?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, do I get a chance?
-That was Cookie, Cookie.
-Oh, I got a chance to do --
to do something else.
-Unh-unh.
Oh, you hide --
I have no idea.
-Anh!
[ Laughter ]
-The remote control?
-Time is up.
-I don't know.
-Anh! Aye!
[ Buzzer ]
-I'm bad at this.
-This is Speed Family Feud!
-What?
What's the Number 3 answer?
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-I was going to help you out.
-Yeah, I should've, yeah.
-Number 1?
[ Ding ]
Oh, dirty laundry.
Interesting, okay, good.
You won that one.
Okay, good.
-Yes.
-Alright, here we go. Round 2.
Let's hear the question.
[ Buzzer ]
Harding.
Basketball. Houston.
James Harding.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
The beard!
I got this.
Jimmy, go home.
[ Laughter ]
-Santa Claus.
-Number 1.
[ Ding ]
You got to buzz it.
-Oh!
-Aah! Aaaaah!
You didn't hit the buzzer!
[ Buzzer ]
-I don't have to.
You already lost that one.
-Oh, that was terrible.
-It's a tie game, huh?
-Why didn't I think of Santa?
-Let's see the other answers.
Number 3 was...?
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-What? Who is that?
-Number 2.
[ Ding ]
-Oh, yeah.
He had a decent beard.
Where did you --
Never mind.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
Round 3.
Let's hear the question.
[ Buzzer ]
Sick.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-Ha!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Oh, yeah, sick.
-Okay, so, Jimmy,
this is the third game I've won.
When are you going to catch up?
-Alright, well,
I'm going to catch up.
What is number 3?
-It was too hot.
[ Ding ]
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's terrible!
-That's mean, yeah.
-Oh, you guys, oh!
-What's 2? What's 2?
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm so happy you said
sick, yeah.
-My question is who looks
in the mirror and says,
"I'm too ugly.
I'm not going on this date"?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Whispering ] It's because the
person they're dating is ugly.
-Ohhh!
-There you go, yeah.
-Got it.
-Alright.
Time for the final round.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is it.
This is for everything.
This one's worth 1,000 points.
-Everything.
-Yeah, here we go.
-$1,000.
-Here we go.
[Indistinct]
-He's going to buy me shoes.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
-Jimmy's buying me shoes.
-Alright, here we go.
Let's hear the question.
[ Buzzer ]
-Big balls!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
No?!
What?!
[ Buzzer ]
-Don't buzz in again.
-What?
I can do it again.
Take 2.
[ Buzzer ]
Blazing balls!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
No?
-Uh --
-I get --
[ Buzzer ]
Brass balls!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
Basketballs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Blue.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ding ]
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Music drowning out voices ]
♪♪
No, no, no, no.
What's 3? What's 3? What's 3?
-Cheated.
[ Ding ]
Meatball,
[ Laughter ]
that's what I was going to say.
-Not even basket?
-No.
2 is...?
[ Ding ]
-Oh, this -- Oh.
-Alright, here we go.
-This audience.
-We're on Nickelodeon, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Valley Girl voice ]
That's totally amazeballs.
-Amazeballs!
[ Laughter ]
-[ Valley Girl voice ]
You're so amazeballs.
-You're amazeballs.
-Amazeballs.
-My thanks to Taraji P. Henson.
Taraji and I are going to play
the Acting Game.
Now, here's how it works.
We have a telephone here.
That's what --
-Is that what that is?
[ Laughter ]
-Kids, that's what telephones
used to look like, yeah.
-What is this, a wire?
Oh.
-And so here's how it works.
I have a stack of cards here,
okay?
With random, ridiculous
scenarios written on them, okay?
-We're going to take turns
answering the phone
and reacting to those scenarios,
but you have to do it
in the most sincerely dramatic
way possible.
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
-Okay?
[ Laughter ]
We're going to put our acting
chops to the test here.
-[ Clears throat, growls ]
-You ready, Taraji?
[ Laughter ]
-Warming up. Wowr! Okay.
Pbbbt!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Red leather. Yellow leather.
Red leather.
Yellow leather. Okay.
-Okay.
Pbbbt!
-[Indistinct]
-Pbbbt!
Bubba, Bubba Gump, Bubba Gump.
-Yeow!
-Bubba, Bubba Gump.
Bubba, Bubba Gump.
-Ba ba ba ba, yes.
-Bubba Gump, Bubba Gump.
Okay. [ Clears throat ]
-Yes, yes. I don't know what
that warmup was, but okay.
-Higgins, you want to give us
a ring, a telephone ring
or something like that?
-Yeah.
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Is that me?
-Oh, sorry.
-It's for me?
-I have to give you --
Sorry, here it is.
Cookie's an astronaut
on a space mission.
NASA calls her to tell her that
she's not coming home tomorrow.
They're extending her mission
for six more months.
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Lucious!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this Houston?
What's wrong?
[ Laughter ]
I'm not coming home for what?
Oh, honey, that's --
that's got to be wrong.
Check the stats. Uh...
No, see, I got
a nail appointment, honey.
I haven't been waxed.
I'm looking like
a woolly mammoth up here.
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no, no, sweetheart.
There are no sidewalks
on the moon, sweetheart.
No, and fur does not
work well in space.
-We're losing it.
-What? Hello? Hey!
Wait a minute! Lucious!
-Alright. Very good. Very nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's always Lucious' fault.
-Got a waxing job.
-Alright. This is mine.
This is mine.
-Okay.
It's Queen Elizabeth
and she needs advice
on what to watch on Netflix.
But you just finished
eating a burrito
and it's not sitting well.
[ Laughter ]
A little gas.
[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-We got to get that phone fixed.
-[ Imitating farting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hello? Hello? Hold on.
Get the dog out of here.
Who is this?
Oh, God, the Queen,
Your Highness.
You are - You have Netflix.
Inter-- Well, let me give you --
-[ Imitating farting ]
-Let me give you --
Hold on a second.
I want to give you some advice
on what to watch.
House --
-[ Imitating farting ]
Help me. Help me.
Watch "House --"
-[ Imitating farting ]
-Just wa-- Just wa--
Just watch "Friends."
I'll talk to you later. Bye.
Or watch "Empire." Bye.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Imitates fart ]
-Great sound effects.
-Thank you, Higgins.
-Yes!
-Okay.
-Taraji, this is the last one.
-I'm crying tears.
-[ Imitates fart ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's sound effects.
You're in the delivery room
with your best friend
who's in the middle of
giving birth to triplets.
-Wow.
-Her husband calls to explain
why he isn't there.
-Oh, Lord.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating phone ringing ]
-Shh. Shh. Keep breathing.
Keep breathing.
This got to begin. Hello?
Where are you?
The second baby is crowning.
Why aren't you here?
What?!
Your car broke down?!
That's like the dog
ate your homework.
If you don't get your ass here,
it's over.
-[ Imitating baby cooing ]
-Ah! That's the second baby!
You have --
Hey, when is the se--
The second baby is on the way.
-Yeah.
-Wait.
Oh, no. That was just
what she ate earlier.
But you better get here!
You better get here or it is --
-[ Imitating baby cooing ]
-Oh! There's baby number three.
We want a divorce.
-That's it right there,
you guys, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Always game, always fun.
Thank you, thank you, thank you
for always playing.
Taraji P. Henson!
We're about to play a game
called Drinko.
Drinko, do you want to explain
how the game works?
-[ Robotic ]
Yes. Yes. Welcome to Drinko.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, God!
-In this game,
you two will
take turns climbing my stairs
and dropping two of your discs
into the Drinko board.
The disc will plink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of
my favorite beverages
of St. Patrick's Day, such as...
Guinness, Shamrock Shake,
and cabbage juice.
-Cabbage juice?
-Cabbage juice is one of
your favorite beverages?
-Yes! I love it, baby.
Then you must drink a cocktail
of those two chosen drinks.
-Okay. Thank you, Drinko.
-You're welcome.
-I wonder who that is.
-I appreciate it, Drinko.
-Well, that's the robot, Drinko.
-Yeah, I know.
-Alright.
-Does he wear glasses?
-I don't know.
Taraji, you go up the stairs
and you can drop your first --
-[ Groaning ]
-Drinko.
Hey, Drinko! Drinko...
-I love cookies.
-[ Laughs ] Stop it!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
-Ready?
-Drop the disc whenever
you're ready.
-[ Chuckles ]
-This is for your --
-Does that tickle?
-You're making yourself a --
-[ Laughs ] Hey, hey, hey, hey!
[ Laughter ]
Get my Christmas goose early.
-Are you getting excited?
-[ Grunting ]
Cabbage juice!
-Is it cabbage juice?!
-[ Laughing ]
-That's your choice.
Now for the second disc.
-I would go more
towards that side.
[ Laughter ]
-So I go again.
-I would.
-[ Growls ]
[ Smacks ]
-Yeah, there you go.
-Drop the disc.
Oh! Hey, hey, hey!
-There you go.
-[ Indistinct vocalizations]
Jameson.
-Jameson.
-Huh?
-Jameson with cabbage juice.
-Aye!
-We call that...
[ Drums playing ]
-Drinko, stop.
Alright.
So here's the Jameson.
-You were supposed to stop it
when I came down.
-And here is the cabbage juice.
-Oh, oh, the drink.
Oh, that part.
Ew!
I might need this cup.
-Alright, here you go.
No! Why'd you smell it?!
Why would you smell it?
Don't smell it.
Just do it.
Just drink it.
-What happens if I don't?
-You just have to.
-[ Sighs heavily ]
[ Drums playing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're such a bitch.
♪♪
-Hey!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Alright, James, it is your turn
to ascend the stairs.
-Alright, thank you.
-That's gonna give me gas.
[ Laughter ]
-This way?
-[ Groaning ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Groaning continues ]
-Drinko, where do you want me
to put my disc?
-[ Laughs ]
You don't have to ask me twice.
-Careful, buddy.
-Go ahead, James,
drop your Drinko discs.
You're used to handling discs.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Eek, ike, ink, ink,
mink, goo, goo, goo,
Boo, bee, bee, bah, bah, bah,
bah, bah, bee, bo!
Four-leaf clover juice.
[ Crowd cheers ]
-What was it?
-Four-leaf clover juice.
-What does that mean?
-Basically, wheatgrass.
-It's the juice of four-leaf
clovers, like wheatgrass.
-Thank you.
-Basically, grass.
-Thank you, Drinko.
-Grass.
-Drinko's like Alexa, yeah.
-It doesn't matter
what you get next.
-Again.
-It really doesn't.
-Let her rip, baby.
[ Laughter ]
There we go. It's coming down.
And it's going to...
-Oh!
-...Irish breakfast tea.
[ Audience groans ]
-So, you have breakfast tea.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whose hands are these?
Come here!
[ Laughter ]
-Show yourself!
-It's Drinko!
Sorry, I apologize.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, this is gonna be
tough, man.
How am I gonna do this?
Wheatgrass juice
and another juice?
-Oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-Want me to smell it for you?
-Ordinary probiotic.
-And -- And tea?
-Tea?
-This might hurt you.
-Smell it first.
Ew, it smells like grass.
-Why would I smell?
I like grass.
I like mowing the lawn.
I like what it does
to your white sneakers
after you mow the lawn
and get all green around it.
This might already be
in my stomach.
-Stop procrastinating.
-Hey, look.
-Go, go, drink, drink,
drink, drink, drink!
-Aaah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
[ Fanfare ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I...
-Okay.
Now it's time
for the final round.
-Uh-oh-oh!
-This is going to be --
This is going to be a race.
-Uh-oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Just make sure that we're safe.
Alright, we're going to
climb up.
We're going to drop our discs
here. Let's take our discs.
And then, the first one
that lands is the winner,
so the second person
has to drink that shot.
Here we go.
-Oh, oh, eee.
-I beat you.
-Uh, uh, uh...
-Drinko.
-Get ready.
-You're very quiet.
Everything okay?
-I'm good.
I'm just having a drinko.
-Drinko, you better not be
looking up my skirt-o.
[ Laughter ]
-I told you, I love cookies.
Whoa!
-Hey, that is so not fair!
-Whoo!
-Absolutely wow.
-What did I get?
-That was such a...
That was so unfair.
-I cheated?
-No, but I love you.
I'll do it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
What is it, though?
Is it bad?
[ Drumroll ]
-Shamrock Shake.
-It's Irish coffee.
-Shamrock Shake?
-And Irish coffee.
-Hell, yeah!
That's fantastic!
[ Audience groans ]
-What is that?
I was gonna order this later!
This is unbelievable!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Ew, that looks --
-What is that, a protein?
-Is that the shake or...
-Let's smell it.
Coffee. That's good.
-Okay. Irish coffee and...
-Shake it, James, shake it.
-And what?!
-Shamrock Shake.
-Oh, that's a Shamrock Shake!
A Shamrock Coffee Shake.
-That's Mickey D's, man.
This is gonna be on the menu
next year.
-That's gonna be everything.
-Whoo!
Happy St. Patrick's Day,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drums pounding ]
Taraji P. Henson, everyone!
I love you!
-The password is..."bubble."
-Taraji, why don't you
start us off?
-Okay.
Everything's a hint,
this is all good.
I'm feeling this, yep,
you got this.
-Gum.
-Blow?
-Ooh!
Quest.
-Burst.
-Bubble.
-Oh!
Oh, my gosh!
-He guessed "sbubble."
He said an "S" on the "B,"
"Sbubble."
-"Swabble," ah.
-Jimmy and Tariq.
-I see what's going on.
-The password is..."shimmy."
-Tariq, you're up first.
-Yah.
-Hey?
[ Laughter ]
-Good answer.
Good answer.
-Oh!
-Oh, hold it, just hold it,
hold it, be cool.
Jimmy.
-Shake.
-Shimmy.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is a barn burner.
-Shimmy, shimmy.
-Shimmy for Jimmy.
-The score, the score,
the score is Sammy Hagar, 55.
-Uh-oh.
-Alright.
-Very nice.
-Whew!
-The password is..."salami."
-No.
-Quest, Quest, you start us off.
-Okay.
-Yeah, I'm not looking.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no,
he's doing his De Niro.
Oh, no, he's doing his De Niro.
-Uh-oh.
-No, no, he's doing
an impression.
-Gabagool.
-Is that hyphenated?
Gabagool?
-Oh, God.
Uh...
-Gabagool.
-"Sopranos"?
-"Sopranos," no.
-Gahh!
-Not Soprano, okay.
Gabagool.
-How do I do this?
Uh...
Hmm.
I don't know,
this is hard. Help me.
-No.
-Come on, you can do this.
-I can do this?
-Yeah, easy.
I got it, Gabagool,
I know that.
-Hoagie.
-Hoagie?
Sub?
-Ooh!
No, down to four points.
-Pastrami.
[ Laughter ]
-You got this.
-Finish the sentence, obviously.
-Pastrami.
-And rye?
-Oh!
Alright,
down to three points.
Pastrami and rye.
-He's not wrong.
-Not wrong, close.
Alright, Taraji, you got it.
-Sandwich.
-Hoagie, pastrami, sandwich...
Gabagool.
-[ Groans ]
-What?
Pastrami.
-You know this.
-Hey, no cheating.
-I'm not cheating!
-You can't use magic.
-Uh...deli?
-No.
Two points, two points.
-Meat.
-Salami.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?
-Oh!
Oh! Okay. Final clue.
-No!
-7 to 5.
How did they get it? Magic.
-Gabagool.
-Jimmy, Jimmy.
-The password is..."yodel."
-Alright, we got to win.
-We have to, we got to...
-Okay, Jimmy,
you're gonna start us off.
-I go first, here we go.
-You got this one,
you got this one.
Come, you got this one.
You can do it.
-Can I?
I can't.
-Yeah, you can.
-No, you can.
-Sing.
[ Audience groaning ]
-Damn, they turned on you quick.
-They turned on me, but...
-What is it? Sing?
-Sing.
-I know, it was a bad clue,
but you can't...
-Who said?
-I looked at the judges,
they said, "No."
-You can't?
-I didn't look at the judges.
-I'm telling you,
-We'll hit that buzzer
-I'm telling you you can't.
-when he says it.
-You can't, you can't,
you can't.
-Okay.
-Song?
-No.
-It's alright, we can get it,
we can get it.
-Four points.
-Don't you --
don't you dare, man.
-♪ Ricola ♪
[ Laughter ]
-You want to play games?
-Echo?
-Ohh!
-Yi-di-oldle-yi-di-da.
-Oh!
-Wait.
She hasn't got it yet.
-Spell that.
-Yee-yee.
-Swedish.
-Oh!
-Swiss Miss!
-Oh, no.
-La-deh-ho!
-Yodel.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my gosh!
The winners!
-Our thanks to Tariq, Questlove,
Taraji P. Henson.